taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like two
fools gonna fight but only one food can
be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
before you say hello before you
introduce the show
look at me because you're beautiful and
i love you hold on wait till this light
goes on
there it is ready oh maybe get you with
the sign we got new signage
okay ready smile joey
there you go right there right there i
understand that's an nft
that's an nft what i understand that's
an nft
if you if you want to know what it is
that's the original tsp
taste buddies what's up you'll sign this
we'll sell it as an nft
thing what the what is going on in this
world
mm-hmm i'm not saying i won't catch you
we need to get in on it we need to get
in on it i don't know
what's going on so we understand so we
can get in on it
taste buddies i'll tell you what's going
on today i'm joe
i'm sal yeah and we're going to be
discussing
as you know from the title as you point
out to us every week
that we say the title even though you
can see the title
uh what do you want from me people it's
free you know what i mean
fruit loops froot loops versus cocoa
pebbles they don't know who's taking
what though yeah they don't know who's
taking what uh yeah it is it's a free
podcast we hope you're enjoying it but
comments the people the love the 99 love
it's awesome it's beautiful
people who are like oh there's too many
ads and it's too short i mean
you know like it's a free thing we get
together for your enjoyment
you can skip pimp puts the ads dead
center if you so choose we try to make
even
we even try to make the ads a little
entertaining so it's not just like you
know but
you could just hit a button and resolve
your issue in one second yes
and and and we always intended for this
thing to be like 30 to 45 and we go 45
to 60
i know but sometimes when we give like a
36 minute episode people raise an
eyebrow
i know and hulu they do that hulu this
is our new artwork by the great
ted ones months months
apologize to ted directly because we
don't want to miss the pronunciation of
his last name but it's munz
if you watch podcasts especially comedy
ones especially like uh
the ones that are popular i think
everyone has uh one of these
beautiful pieces and now we we get to
join that club so thank you so much
ted it's really gorgeous it's like
gorgeous it really is like i'm in awe of
this thing
i don't know how you even begin to start
to make this thing
i don't know but uh with tiles but then
it's based on the artwork
lost after tiles yeah that's all i would
know is i'd go i need some tiles and
then i wouldn't know what to do
do you think he used to just put in like
he used to just do grout work in
bathrooms then he was like i'm gonna
transition to no really because how do
you get into tiles heavy
yeah you know you know came in and goes
there's something beautiful inside of
you yeah like you don't get proficient
in tile work without first going through
a couple of bathrooms right right
a couple of half baths you know and then
you start to make your way in the half
bath game
and then someone says let me ask you a
question can you make just a square of
tile for me to hang on the wall and then
you say yes then
you start experimenting with we're
trying to start his journey ted
maybe it was maybe it went the other way
maybe the foreman came in
on a a bathroom job and the foreman goes
ted i need to talk to you he goes listen
to me
you want to put the faces of your
favorite podcasters in tile you do it on
your own
you know this guy for a job every time i
walk into a bathroom it's not a comedian
and tile on the wall
[Laughter]
stop daydreaming this was supposed to be
a floral pattern it turned into joey
diaz's face
um let's see here let's i want to give
him a proper uh at least his social
channel too
because this this is just like above and
beyond and we just yes we really
appreciate
this while you look that up i will
elaborate a little bit more on our
today's uh topic sal and i have been
kicking around the idea of a breakfast
cereal episode for a while sal
from the be i am going to reveal whose
team is what is that okay
for sure and tell them though because we
we we put one we agree on
the best cereal yeah we had to kick that
to the curb we agreed that
uh uh captain crunch with crunch berries
is the greatest cereal of all time
at least right now for me it is and it's
been for a while i've never
i i i don't think it can be rivaled uh
in my opinion
uh but so we agreed on that so then we
had to go to
second favorite serials which even that
was kind of tough because
second favorite obviously isn't as as
pat you're not
quite as passionate as your favorite but
you're still passionate uh
sal from the jump on second favorite
cereal
was froot loops from the beginning i had
to kind of keep rotating mine
uh until we found what we thought was
something i felt strongly about but was
also
where the adversary which is i said if
you're gonna go fruit i gotta go
chocolate
and uh you know and both these cereals
have been around since
well for a long well well cocoa pebbles
came out i believe in 1971
uh alongside fruity pebbles which i also
love but again i wanted to do chocolate
versus fruit
uh fruit loops though have been around
since the 30s is it
wow are you serious oh for 1945 wow
1945 froot loops was given to us during
the war
yeah what's ted's thing before ted i
guess
i want to say muns i think it's muns
m-u-n-z
mosaic m-o-s-a-i-c uh ted mun's mosaic
art
on instagram and you can take a look at
all of the different
signage he's done for uh for everything
it looks like from podcasts to even
legos so it's
great work ted and we appreciate you
yeah thank you ted
and thank you all for your support and
the wonderful love that you're showing
all of us we really really appreciate it
we can't believe
oh the channel that no press channel uh
is that
a hundred thousand give me some love
subscribers in in eighteen
short weeks we we we're we're floored
they send you a plaque apparently
apparently we're getting some kind of
plaque it was great just to be
just to be it was great just to just to
make an account
it was great just to make a login and
yes that's all we ever wanted really
from this we said let's let's shoot for
the login and password and if we get
hundreds of thousands of people great
um i can't believe that the uh the the
the fruity pebble was around before i
was born the pebble
the cocoa and fruity pebble yes
flintstones hannah
stones are that's you know it's pretty
old school cartoon you know you forget
because we all grew up
not we all but guys our age at least or
people our age grew up with the
flintstones and
you know when when i was six it never
registered in my head that
this was shot in the 60s or created in
the 60s and it was based on the
honeymooners right yes was it not
which i never realized as a kid even
though i liked the honeymooners as a kid
yeah
and when i got older uh and i'm talking
like i was in my
30s and i bought a honeymooner's box set
and as i was watching it that's when it
the light bulb
feels like yeah i was like holy [ __ ] uh
the
the flintstones is based on this yeah
yeah like it's based on the honeymooners
and by the way
everyone knows now jackie gleason
canceled
because he used to threaten alice with
violence
and yes i did just confuse jackie
gleason and ralph crampton
uh they're this did you know that ralph
cramden used to
tell his wife that he would beat her
until she landed on the moon yeah yeah
yeah you know what they got away tuned
in
what they got away with back then but i
mean he would be off that bus
job in a split second it's never like
but it's
he doesn't say like i'm going to
legitimately
get you out of no but there's a very
special episode where he's like i'm
gonna
really hurt you today he says he goes
you make me so mad i would like to
how and then she goes you're a fat load
and then everybody laughs at him
i don't know it's fine right yeah but
it's when when fred flintstone
uh really laces into uh i don't even
know their names anymore
yeah his wife's name will wilma he never
said well
i'm gonna punch you no they left the
violin when they transitioned to
animation they left out the
threats of violence yeah and so did the
so did by the way
the movie version cedric the
entertainer's movie version of the
honeymooners
left out all of the fighting so i was
like
what am i watching i'm just now watching
just a normal movie about couples
with these names that don't make any
sense i'm just watching like an
african-american rom-com at that point
why would a guy in 2002 be named ralph
kramden this doesn't make any sense
what names nowadays like if you saw a
baby right now and i said oh this is the
this is my son
hank would you be like that's a choice
i think i actually think hank is a name
that you could still
that that almost has like a throwback
quality almost like a timeless
like a classic but but yeah like like uh
i feel like it'd be weird now if you
named your kid like
like joe or bobby or something like just
like one of the classic
uh you know house i don't think joe but
it's like i don't even think like like
it's like i don't even mean like a name
that hasn't been around in a long time i
mean more of a name that just doesn't
suit a baby
oh hank doesn't shoot a baby yes like
how do you like there's a lot a lot of
older names seem to be in line with that
right here barnabas
[Laughter]
that would be homer man barnes would be
an awesome
name edith i actually really like i like
old-fashioned names i really do
older names barnabas shutterstock is a
great name
that's a great name that's a really
great
look at that last one lemuel how do you
say that lemuel
lemuel no let me let me well
that's it i never heard that name but i
will say that i didn't it is weird to
think that people were enjoying bowls of
fruity pebbles
five years before i was conceived yeah i
know and i
i'm very curious to know if it tasted
different back i mean it must have right
so when did the flintstones actually
come how long did it take them to get
their cereal
and by the way are they they're they're
not producing new episodes
of the flintstones nowadays are they
well they made
two flintstones live action movies right
but what i'm saying is
okay so 60 and the ceo came out in 70.
so it took them 10 years
well let me ask you a question when did
the flintstones go off the air let's see
if it's still in production
i mean it is wild that they haven't made
new flintstones episodes
it went off the air in 1966 and then
they got cereal five years after it went
off the air
okay and that cereal has been around
that cereal's been around for for
51 years after that that's insane
so kids today like you're building my
arms
you didn't co-opt the pebble to
something else like say all right it was
just be free pills but a kid today now
looks at the box they only know the
flintstones unless they see it in
syndication on a network
they only know the flintstones from the
box of cereal
yeah no no no i think that's crazy and
like what's what's really weird is
the flintstones is almost like the star
trek
of cartoons where like the initial run
was very
short yet somehow it became part of the
like almost like jackass you know yeah
toss it all the way around
yeah uh do they still have the vitamins
oh yeah
oh they are how are they sustaining
branding
when the the the thing has been off the
air for 60 years i guess it just became
about
it it was like any it was like so many
other products where it's like no it's
just a cartoon mascot now
when were there ever any other
flintstones shows pimp
after 66 besides those two horrendous
live-action movies they released i mean
i don't know what i would have thought
would make a good
flintstones live-action movie those
longest running network animated
television series for three decades
until the simpsons
six years was the record until the
simpsons
damn but it was the first i think it was
the first like prime
time cartoon you know like it wasn't
like a kid's
experience it is funny though honey
winners have zero branding
zero the flintstones really just took
the took that
zero yeah they're not even associated
with the creators are completely
independent right
of the honeymooners and the phones they
just took that as inspiration yeah they
just
they really took its essence and then
ran with it and 70 years later they're
still hawking vitamins and pebbles
on the backs of hannah barbera but
really like it's really off of the
honeymooners who probably got nothing
from that
look at this they got pimp scroll up a
little bit they did television sessions
oh that's
how they kept relevant they did an
animated feature
but look how many television special
television specials there are right oh
no they kept going they kept going no
look flintstone comedy hour what
whatever that was the flintstone kids
the flintstone comedy show the kindness
show the rubbles all right there's a new
show yabba-dabba dinosaurs click on that
that's new look at this where
how is that new uh the series focuses on
the lives of the best friends pebbles
flintstone and bam bam rubble
who are joined by dino for many
adventures in the stone age
the series is scheduled to be released
as part of boomerang uh okay so that's
going to be
i named my kid bam bam one day yeah i
have a kid and even bam bam
you shoot me straight no
you don't no i would shoot you straight
you'd be like what are you doing of
course
you wouldn't i i expect i expect that
you would yeah yeah i would do that
with a far less offensive name than bam
bam i would do that with you
pebbles yeah what are you doing it's my
daughter pebbles would you be like i
need to talk to you and for real like
you can't do that sal you can't do that
you could name your daughter coco
coco pebbles coco yeah you think it's
rude of people when they
the parents that name their kids things
that are like off the reservation yeah i
think
do you think it's selfish of them 100
100
my friend jim i love him dearly he told
me once he wanted
now we were younger we were in college
but he told me he wanted to name his kid
hill and i yelled at him say that again
now he wanted to name his kid weep hill
weep hill because he heard it in a
weezer in this weezer song my name is
jonas
and he goes i think that's a really cool
name i wouldn't want to name my son weep
hill and i go you're an [ __ ] if you
do that your friend is an [ __ ]
no he's not he he came around on it all
right well then he's a reformed [ __ ]
yeah but i was like i was like that's
i know you think that's kind of what can
you do with that it's basically sounds
yeah didn't uh musk name is kid like an
equation
a math equation so what do they call
them
a let me pull up the name everyone needs
to simmer down
i mean remember when when it was like
crazy that bruce willis named his
daughter uh
him and demi moore named their daughter
scout remember when that was like yes
now scout is like it would be like
adorable yeah even like moon zappa was
like
that was like considered crazy now i'd
just be like oh moon that's like a
normal yeah like
isn't it like a northwest is that that's
kanye and an apple
apple is uh isn't that uh uh uh
what's her face pepper potts quinnis
paltrow yeah yeah yeah
i have my my little cousin slash niece
named olive who's a big fan of the show
shout out to olive has a lovely name i
love the name
my goddaughter's name is olive yeah kurt
braunholler
and his wonderful wife lauren their
daughter oliver is my goddaughter
really yeah i'm dead serious well that
just took me
for a loop yeah i know kurt i knew we
had a kid too
and i had no idea that you were the
godfather of a child kurt and i had a
podcast at the time
where we explored emotions and on the
podcast he asked me
as they were expecting he asked me if i
would be their daughter's godfather
no i haven't seen him in two years
now is that on you now though
was it in a religious capacity or was it
in a um
uh not at all bestowed upon you just
like we
we just think this would be nice listen
to me if i ever take a
a fall i want to give you the honor of
supporting and raising my child
yeah yeah yeah no no that is what god
listen
we have good news for you yeah if we
ever meet our demise
untimely you're going to bear all the
burden
of the life that we were trying to bring
up um
me when i tell you there was no interest
in them
having me raise this kid there was no
there was no part of that
no but that's because i am the god
parent to many children yeah
um all my sisters kids basically and
there are a lot of them
and um and then some friends too and i
take the responsibility seriously
i do i really do but i'm not like
necessarily religious but like i feel
like
it's it's it's them telling me that like
we
we you we we trust and love you so much
that
like that's where the position would be
we would trust you with our kids
that's kind of what it is right yeah
yeah i i think
well the godparent's role is a moral and
religious
one uh it's the role of a sponsor and
being named as a godparent a child does
not create a legal relationship between
the god parents
oh really is that a legal bond both of a
child's parents were to die
the godparent would would not
automatically become a child's guardian
no i love that they have to clarify that
because it's true people probably are
just like they think that's what it
means
because like in no unspoken terms it
that's not what he was at the percentage
of the percentage of parents that get
hit by a bus
what percentage do you think the
godparents then take ownership of the
child like
less than one percent is it all [ __ ]
uh if you're a godparent well
i mean that had to take possession of a
child for some reason or another
uh let us know sound off in the comments
right i just want to know like i don't
know i'm not trying to make light
if you know the parents getting by bus
or anything but i know although that
would be
you know what it's quite
i'm taking that back we're way off track
here
let's get on to the theme of the show
don't sound off or do and tell us
exactly what it was like like do you
feel like
you weren't prepared for this could you
ever prepare for it has it been the
financial approach
what we do here it tastes good then you
know what take it off this is
and god forbid god forbid uh chris
brings up cereal
i'll tell him where to stick it just so
you know there's a mutual response i
want to know if
i'm going to get if i all right yeah
yeah the cereal the cereal episode of
taste buds is the debate that never was
apparently yeah
i want to know if my if the show i do
with you will get the same respect
on hey babe that we're giving hey babe
right now i'm saying slide this to your
show
yeah i won't say anything to chris i'll
start talking about
better cereals and i'll see if he was
like you should save this for derose i
i'll see if he saw you guys talking
about something that we've talked about
what's so funny is we mother i remember
sleeping
these mother they have to have it all
it's not enough that they get 600
every thursday i gotta see it posted
three hours ago
six hundred thousand views hey babe
i'm just like all right
and i tune in and they're like you know
like i don't know i like uh
chips ahoy better than almost how what
would it be if we had just it was just a
talk
it was just a podcast about talking
about the episode of this podcast
no but no pressure you guys are doing i
mean we got to make 100 000 subscribers
in four months thanks to you guys man
this is so and
we're full steam ahead on it's
incredible uh it's
it's incredible let's look look i do
like talking to you about non-food items
though
yeah i love it yeah usually the first
step is the first episode back
recording wise is the first episode
we've recorded in about a month
so usually the first one back recording
we have a little more preamble a little
more catching up a little more shooting
the breeze right yeah
because we know that once we start the
bell
or ring the bell rather yeah that'll go
the gloves are off and then you're my
enemy
shoot the breeze where'd that come from
what does that mean shoot the breeze
shoot the [ __ ] shoot the breeze why both
it's probably just
i'm big on etymology what about you
uh sometimes
sometimes originating in southern united
states the phrase seems to date from the
late
1800s a slang phrase alluding to taking
talking does that say talking into the
wind like needless talk
ah shoot debris so just just go ahead
yeah you're blowing and you're blowing
hot air it was first recorded in 1919 in
the variant
okay so what about shoot the [ __ ]
uh that's just probably [ __ ] the
[ __ ] which is sh it's
like it's a co-op of that phrase
probably right whoa oh my god
norman mailer coined that phrase
wow in in a letter
wow wow that guy
you want to watch wild stuff man there's
a great
uh clip on youtube of norman mailer
and gore vidal and norman three names
that
i i wonder if a percent the way that i
look at podcasts now like
if we have any younger i know everyone
you're talking about yeah it's so funny
but norman miller comes out drunk
because it was back when you could do
that on tv
sure and he calls out gore vidal for
referring
alluding that he's a nazi to in
something
it's very it's honestly very relevant
relevant to now
like you know i didn't call you a nazi i
just said he's like no you clump me in
and it gets nasty man oh really wild
it's a wild clip yeah it's fun to watch
it's really cute
all right here we go now look let's get
to let's get to what the bees knees here
don't look up the etymology
bee's knees hold
all right you ready yeah babe we've shut
out the i sent it out like two i got
it you got here two and a half hours ago
i sent it out then i know i know all
right
cheers i'm back on the sauce i wasn't
last time we
oh you're look at this the guy that
doesn't drink he's right i don't think
we have done his job but a company sent
us a
thing so we tried it i mean what do you
want me to do here we can say the name
right
no all right no we get
you know all right let's we do that all
the time we plug people all the time
all right fair enough uh he blows
something to ourselves
let's get started we've already talked
quite a bit i here okay let's
here's here's where i'd like to begin
the debate and i'm going to throw it to
you first
oh why
froot loops what strikes you as
as wonderful about fruit loops because
i've always found them to be a terribly
you know middle of the road
underwhelming cereal
that's interesting because i think you
know i think normal i think the
powerhouse cyril so we both agree that
we like right now at least that captain
crunch with berries is the best
right um i think that's a powerhouse
cereal then right underneath that
uh well that's my favorite and i would
argue it's one of the most popular
sales-wise right underneath that comes
probably
five or six years to me that i think
have stood the test of time that are
gonna be powerhouse opponents
okay i would say uh i hear a lot i'm
surprised you did not
when i said i was going to pick fruit
loops i'm surprised you didn't go up
against me with something more like a um
frosted flakes a you know you
very universally loved well-branded
cereal that
has really not that many bells and
whistles because it doesn't need it
um i think that would have been a really
tough opponent for me
i think i'm gonna take you with coco
peppers you know me dude i don't
you know both of us i'm not gonna fight
for it unless i'm really passionate
about it and i'm not passionate about i
like frosted flakes but i'm not
passionate i like rice krispies i'm not
passionate sure
i'm passionate about cocoa pebbles i was
gonna do fruity pebbles
but we thought it was a little too
similar it's too on the nose and as far
as fruit goes
a fruit cereals go i do think froot
loops is the king you got tricks in
there
you got some big you got fruity pebbles
beats them all i'm surprised you didn't
go lucky charms i'll tell you that
lucky charms is yeah well that magically
it's just yeah it's
it's just news look i'll put it above
fruit uh fruit loops though i'll put
lucky charms above fruit
you would and i think it's a snooze yeah
i think that as a kid i really like
lucky charms but i ate them so much that
i got sick of them
hasn't happened with froot loops i'll
say froot loops
i started i started with froot loops
uh when it was like just orange red and
yellow
it was three rings bro yeah three colors
i know i go back
yeah they since added purple green blue
but that wasn't
until the 90s yeah that wasn't where i
was so fruitlips for me is it's just
it's just delicious okay it does not
feel like real fruit at all no it
doesn't that's one of the things i don't
like
it doesn't mean to it doesn't have to no
cereal does fruity pebbles if you're
gonna put it up against it
tricks also now they they used to be
just
like kicks colored kicks right now they
changed them into the shape of the fruit
and that also added marshmallows to
tricks yeah that could take a walk
all right marshmallows but i'll tell you
this and i would blame
i would say more so tricks than than
froot loops
they have i believe that froot loops and
tricks both carry quite a perfumey or
colognish
fruit uh uh scent i don't mind it
[Music]
i mean i'm nothing if i'm not telling
you why is that so funny
i don't know i mean i'm not thinking i'm
not honest it's a weird thing to not
mind
i don't mind it i will tell you that
it's closest competitor i think
tricks is second i think it's the
closest competitor is fruity pebbles the
brethren of cocoa pebbles
but i'll tell you the whole pebble
family
in flintstone family has a big issue and
it's they get soggy and milk too
fast they turn pasty and they coagulate
and they get together
and if you that is their best feature
that is the the clumping
if you call it the clumping the clumping
yeah in a in a pebble cereal yeah that
sounds
is the best part that sounds appetizing
the clumping
yeah that sounds great well i mean look
you want to talk about you know people
talk about
how captain crunch rips up the roof of
your mouth
uh froot loops rips up the roof of your
mouth those circles those captains
captain crunch will mess you up right
they're like those little barrels
and by the way you got to wait but the
thing about captain crunchers
they'll they'll mess you up so badly
that if you wait a little while
there's this a window of
non-invasive
that still happens before the sogginess
yes because they're so
dense with crunch that you get this like
a way wider of a window with crunch
berries
to eat it where it's soaked in milk
that's not gonna slice you up but it's
still crunchy
you can't be an amateur you can't eat it
right away then you're going to slice up
there's no i get it but i think fruit
loops are the same thing and i would say
even worse
because they're the the the diameter of
those loops
okay the crunch captain crunch is shaped
in a way
you can slide it back to a molar you can
jaw it a little bit
those roops loops go rolling down your
tongue
like loose wheels down the street all
right
and they don't go right across the roof
of your mouth well
i don't know about that metaphor why i
don't think it only makes perfect sense
i never scooped up well because i never
scooped up
a spoonful of uh froot loops and threw
them in my mouth and said to myself whoa
these are rolling down my tongue to the
back of my throat like a tire down the
street i'm saying
they just the metaphor is it doesn't
doesn't the way they land in your mouth
okay if you get one of those fruits they
feel like little fruity frisbees in my
mouth like
like like ring toss and by the way their
sin even the profile is thin
a froot loop has never cut my mouth i
wouldn't because because a
captain crunch has those they're like
almost like these little dowels like
these little like
almost like they're like earplug shapes
they're like barrels we're not arguing
captain
crunch the rings crack under pressure
with way less
pound percent i disagree completely by
the way
look at the f and pimp in the post if
you could put this
this exact cover of fruit loops up on
the wall look how
sad that cereal looks look how
depressing
it looks like it looks like a fake
cereal
it's three miserable colors also toucan
sam
sucks
he's cool he's cool as [ __ ] man and i
love that old version of him too
i love this toucan sam he he has never
been our like he has never lost his
relevance to me
i think he stood there you're gonna put
hold on you're gonna put
toucan sam against fred flintstone
are you out of your mind he doesn't have
his own cartoon
but fred flintstone flintstone has been
riding a wave he created in the 60s
and he got a strong hold over vitamins
and pebbles
and he never let go you'd show me fred
flintstone outside of a vitamin and a
pebble
he said show me who can't see him
outside of cereal but that's his only
thing
oh my god you're nuts dude so fred
flintstone is bad for diversifying
no i i actually i'm over it is there a
toucan sand movie starring john goodman
no there isn't oh that bomb that
wouldn't have brought that well i'm just
saying
terrible offense to john goodman shout
out it sucked
it was a [ __ ] movie offense to john
goodman he should be ashamed of that
film
put into the argument that john goodman
for some reason because john goodman
played fred flintstone in a live
action feature that has something to do
with the the credibility of let's
talk about let's talk about sam it's
such a great talk
hey taste buddies uh joe and sal here to
talk to you about keeps
keeps is a hair loss prevention
medication
yeah that is prescribed to you through a
virtual doctor conveniently
have consultations online it's delivered
straight to your door every three months
you do not have to leave your home
treatments start at just 10
bucks a month right amazing prevention
is keen so this is what keeps us about
it's about keeping
what you have if you're bald it's not
going to grow your hair that's what i
like about this product
beans are a genie bottle it's not some
kind of magical miracle
right you know bs hey we're promising
you impossible things it's saying hey
if it's falling out and you want to slow
that down you want to hopefully stop
that
use keeps hence the name keeps makes a
lot of sense so blow drying your hair
you're going out on the weekend yeah
beautiful like like a travolta type
esque saturday night fever thing then
one day
there's a little too much hair in your
brush you want to pump the brakes
yeah keeps yeah exactly for you you go
from
saturday night fever travolta and you're
heading towards god each revolt
[Laughter]
and you really want to just pause that
around face-off travel
anyway if you're ready to take action
and prevent hair loss go to k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash taste buds that's
k-e-e-p-s
dot com taste buds you're gonna receive
your first month of treatment for free
all right once more k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash taste buds
get your first month free dot com slash
taste buds
travolta wouldn't have it any other way
taste buddies
we all love food around this place you
know it we know it
but sometimes you gotta cut down on the
carbs sometimes you gotta cut down on
the sugar
sometimes you just gotta cut back in
general but why
when you cut back do you have to deprive
yourself of those delicious
treats that you love so much you don't
number one not anymore of those being
cereal right yeah you talked about this
uh magic spoon is what we're talking
about magic spoon comes in
am i wrong no it's a zero grams of sugar
cereal
it's got 13 to 14 grams of protein in
each serving
and it's only got four net grams of
carbs
in each serving of the cereal yeah what
else does it have let's see
it's only 140 calories per serving uh
it's keto-friendly gluten-free
grain-free soy-free low-carb and gmo
free that's a lot of freeze a lot of
stuff you're getting free there
they're not going to charge you for the
gluten they're not going to charge you
for the grain
they're not charging you for the soy all
free and we've got some exciting news
magic spoon is
relaunching the blueberry flavor one of
the favorite flavors that was
it was out of stock and now it's back in
stock people it was sold out you
couldn't get it that was my favorite one
of all the ones that i did you have a
mix because i like mixing did you ever
take the chocolate
and the peanut butter and then make
chocolate peanut butter you know i'm not
a wild guy like that i try to keep it
you know i
keep everything in its own lane i don't
love chocolate cereals as you know
i know but when i mix the chocolate and
the peanut butter together it made a
nice
midday treat i'll tell you this the
blueberry so delicious
didn't need to be mixed that's it and
that's it if you're listening from
canada
magic spoon now ships there as well and
you can also build your own box don't
forget
uh there's available flavors to build
your very own custom bundle
uh and those flavors are cocoa fruity
frosted peanut butter and cinnamon so i
guess then in
oh okay so you could build a bundle of
those sure you can't mix it into this
mixing your frosted with your cinnamon
all right we're not getting we haven't
gone there yet it's magic spoon it's not
miracle spoon
it's only a matter of time go to
magicspoon.com tastebuds to grab some
blueberry or a custom bundle of cereal
to try it today
and be sure to use our promo code
tastebuds at checkout to save five
dollars off your first order
this offer is now good anywhere in the
us or canada as you mentioned
but only when you use our code at
checkout that's right magicspoon.com
tastebuds use promo code tastebuds save
yourself five bucks off your first order
take it easy let's talk about let's talk
about who toucan sam is ripped off of
versus who fred flintstone is really
cool
follow his nose oh okay i love him oh
i'm going to get to it
hold on how great is it that they put
they they they they um
what do you call it when they uh they
stylized fruit i love that
the double o's they use the loops
because loops is lops so fruit is
fr you know you've seen that it's uh
it's f yeah oh did i spell it wrong in
the
did i spell it wrong in the probably oh
i don't want to look at the results
don't look at the results i wrote
fine i wouldn't have remembered the
little style but who cares
sweet it means something here's what
here's the thing fred flintstone is
is [ __ ] fred flintstone is ripped from
jackie gleason
yeah one of the funniest human beings
that has ever been
undoubtedly let me finish undoubtably
toucan sam
is a ripoff of groucho marx and i'll say
it
the most overrated comedy figure of all
time
groucho martin the overrated overrated
of all the comedy classic people where
people go
dude you got it you got it hearty blah
blah blah blah blah
everything you go back and watch groucho
marx and it's him with those
dumb fake eyebrows ah i've seen an
elephant in my pajamas today
he they stink yeah but if you guys if
you listen to the
like they do have they they are one of
the like trailblazers of that
quick case blaze the trails i don't care
all right
groucho marx has nothing to goddamn do
with fruit loops from kellogg he's who
can sam is based on yeah he could take a
walk toucan sam
is uh two kids google it toucan sam has
been around since the war 1945 now yeah
since when groucho marx was around
but around 80 years i don't have to he's
not
he's not groucho marx is not carrying
toucan sam
okay toucan sam has has earned the right
to be his own individual identity nobody
says
toucan sam you mean groucho marx no but
i'm saying and nobody says fred
flintstone
uh ralph cramden no but i'm saying if
you want to talk mascots and their value
and what makes one better than the other
i'm saying even the people they're
ripped off of fred flintstone is better
than than than two cameras over the
flintstones
was a cartoon i i never really loved
love desserts
i love the vitamins what's two can sam's
catchphrase
follow my nose
yeah i believe it is no it's not well
what is it then he doesn't have one i
don't think
i just told you it is his catchphrase
follow my nose
yeah because he's gonna be the first
loops and he knows where they are and he
goes there he leads you to the loops
who can't sam follow your nose okay okay
you're right i'm sorry
yeah all right i mean i didn't remember
that being what does toucan say i'm
famous for saying
follow my nose it always knows it always
knows yeah okay
you think that's better than
yabba-dabba-doo yeah but
do no no let's let's let's let's let's
let's
hold on to off of the food here well
hold on a second right yabba-dabba-doo
existed before fruity pebbles man
okay yeah friends fred flintstone says
that yeah
but froot loops toucan sam was creative
four froot loops and that slogan follow
my nose it always knows
it's for the cereal sorry i'm not gonna
put it up against the abba daba do you
have another do is his
catchphrase in the zeitgeist that's not
fair okay like
it's from the show i mean look i don't
give a [ __ ] about the slogans dude
let's get back to what you're doing
anyway we still haven't touched on cocoa
pebbles or fruit loops i got a lot to
say
the clumping of first of all a chocolate
cereal
i'll pit against a fruit cereal any day
of the week
there's no way what are you talking
about i hate chocolate cereals
i have i do not eat chocolate i don't
like
chocolate as breakfast i do not like it
why my body rejects it i don't want the
taste of chocolate i don't associate the
taste of chocolate
with breakfast i just don't want it i
just don't like it i don't i don't eat
chocolate cereals at all
i don't and i'll eat fruit cereals till
the cows come home
and the best of the best fruits is fruit
loops i love the scent i love the flavor
it's just the right
fruit flavor for me tricks if you like
eat tricks it's like
it's fruit too but it's it's i don't
know man there's something about fruit
loops that has a taste it's almost like
mcdonald's to me they have this like
captivating hold on that they haven't
unlocked
that fruit fly after you with the things
you said about mcdonald's on this show
when that was my pro mcdonald's argument
i don't mean that no
don't you wendy's i just say mcdonald's
because mcdowell is more popular but
people are always just like i don't know
obviously there's better burgers than
mcdonald's but mcdonald's just has this
thing that we already know my exact my
exact argument
that you said was [ __ ] and that's
why it sucks i didn't say it was
[ __ ] but i just said
wendy's was better i'm just using
mcdonald's because it's a more popular
look i'm just fruit loops you can't tell
you can't tell
one loop from the next so so so you can
you can argue that it's a fruit flavor
what do you mean you can't tell one loop
from the next you're telling me you
could
oh please make this argument please are
you ready
please
flavored cereal blows it never tastes
like chocolate it tastes like cereal's
version of
chocolate now and you think that fruit
loops tastes like real food chocolate
there's cookie crispies
and you think fruit loops taste like
real fruit no
yeah okay no but fruity pebbles
it almost becomes like we're not talking
it becomes like a muddy yes no
and it turns the milk into something
magical it turns normal milk into
chocolate milk at the end i want that up
there with frosted flakes milk at the
end
no i don't like chocolate cereals it
tastes like a weird processed chocolate
it gets this slime let me leave froot
loops for a moment and focus more on the
pebbles
go ahead the pebbles have this weird
chemical reaction that happens to them
when they're in milk longer than 90
seconds
it's not a chemical reaction oh it sure
does it's a physical reaction
well it's also a chemical let's not make
it sound like the shiro's combust but
you're combining ingredients
that have chemicals you might need milk
and then wholesome
natural cereal no there's definitely
words you can't pronounce on the side of
that ingredient spot
you know what i mean though you have
such a small window
with fruity pebbles or cocoa but let's
just keep it on cocoa pebbles we have
such a small window
to pour that milk in and get that bowl
down because most people
don't want the coagulated that's not
true
that's why yes it is cocoa powder that's
why you stick with it
and then this weird sheen
gets gets glossed over the pebble
and it gets this weird mushy
just really weird the the actual texture
that happens after
a minute and a half of pebbles and milk
is gross you get
you get it's gross you can actually any
fan of the pebbles brands of cereal
will agree with me you get
spoonfuls when when when it's right and
you know what you're doing you get
spoonfuls
that are crispy on the top and soft
and mushy on the bottom with some of
that it's almost like eating pork
cracklin
except that's chocolate cereal there's a
crispy
skin layer on the top and then this
wonderful succulent meat just to help my
argument
can you just repeat that whole sentence
again it's like eating a wonderful pork
cracklin as a cereal except chocolate
flavored yeah which by the way
again great metaphor that's not a
metaphor it's great
it's crispy and soft and succulent yeah
no no
when i'm when i'm just wake up my alarm
goes off
and i'm like oh my god what do i have
ahead of me today how am i going to
tackle the world today yeah i know what
you can i stand up
you know i don't brush my teeth and i
wait left to eat okay i go into the
things the
morning sun is shining in i take a nice
cold glass and look and i say
boy oh boy to start this day i would
love a chocolate version
of a pork stretcher stretch it out
longer next time i want a chocolate
version of a pork cracklin stat what are
you doing a one-man show about my joke
at 907 a.m to make me start my day
i want to get onto the city bus after
eating a bowl of chocolate pork
cracklins
that's what i want let's talk sales and
i believe
cracklings he said i believe that now
now pimp i only saw briefly the numbers
for
for pebbles but i believe it outsold
fruit loops uh
fruit loops is at the number seven spot
and fruity pebbles is at
10. that's that's nearly discernible
wait but these cocoa pebbles even chart
no
no when it comes to the pebbles fruity
dominates coco which is another weird i
wanted to talk well
look i'll tell you this fruity pebbles
versus fruity pebbles is a better cereal
it's a one
look at the look at the visual fruity
pebbles
pimp pull up pull up a fruity pebbles
next to fruit loops photo please
the visual even of the two next to each
other it's no
contest fruity pebbles box is really
great with the visuals oh god but once
you crack the plastic open and you pour
it into the bowl fruity pebbles fails on
all accounts buddy
look at this it's you know what you know
how i'll eat a fruity pebble
i'll eat it like out of the box like i'm
eating chips or something like that but
like
pouring milk on it i gotta tell you and
you know what you know what else
fruity pebbles is actually dude you're
going to turn cocoa pebbles we keep
talking
about it's too
sweet i got to tell you something after
i ate one bowl of fruity pebbles
and we're talking cocoa pebbles i'm
assuming it's the same you get this rush
of like i
how many bowls can you have of chocolate
pebbles
i was going to say that i never ate
fruity froot loops
don't leave that hold on don't leave
that picture because i want to get no no
finish your point but i
never use fruit loops to the point where
i was like i can't eat another bowl i
feel sick every time i eat froot loops i
have to be like
don't you dare eat another bowl and [ __ ]
look at these next to each other look at
the vibrance of the
of the pebbles cereal versus that bland
that
the colors of fruity pebbles it looks
like the way uh
uh a housewife does decorates her house
in the middle of
idaho do you know what i mean it's a lot
of mobs
and it's gonna bend potpourris
of fruity pebbles the fruit loops excuse
me the froot loops looks like looks like
middle american
household wallpaper that looks like
every painting in a ramada inn over the
bed
and you know it does yes it does look at
those colors it's
awful you are off the mark today with
your comparisons no i'm not
look at those colors pastel cereal oh
look down in a bowl of fruit loops i've
been like this reminds me of remodeling
artwork pastel cereal you don't help
yourself
look the fruity the fruit the fruity
pebbles i won't i will
call spade a spade the fruity pebble is
that is that okay to say that yes it is
okay
i said it i'm like that's antiquated i
hope no one thinks i'm saying that
i always took it as a card game thing
okay yeah that's what it is
that's what it is i thought so but
people don't focus on it and make it
worse
sometimes you say something like that 90
years ago this meant something else
look i'm talking about cocoa pebbles all
right i i agree that fruity pebbles
is um is vibrant it's way more vibrant
and i will give you that
but it looks vibrant vibrant is not
going to win the argument they have
about pebbles
they have pebble cereal when you go to
like a lot of like yogurt frozen yogurt
bars
pebble cereal will be a topping at the
yogurt bar
i've never seen fruit loops look at pimp
shaking his head quietly
because he knows who's right that's
because that's simply a function of this
by the way calling it pebbles post this
post that that creates uh
their post here post post has a sack on
them
what do you mean he's calling it pebbles
they're little chips little flaky chips
they look like little rocks no they
don't
do no they don't yes they do they look
it looks like what fred hammerstein at
the place he works yes it does they look
like these
little chip like flaky chips oh look
they look like [ __ ] favorite hero
cookie has a fruity pebbles flavor
they don't have a trix favorite look
oreo fruity pebbles okay
look all i'm saying is they got they got
stones calling them pebbles
okay they don't look like pebbles they
should be called fruity and cocoa
mini flakes i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm
gonna and again we need to go back to
cocoa pebbles but i promise you this
if you looked up cereal recipes you
would find
several that involve pebble cereal you
will find almost
none that involve fruit loops i promise
you that i i've seen a frulou version of
a rice krispy treat i've seen
as well as i've seen i once saw a man
that had two heads what does that mean
yeah we've seen everything i'm not
talking about that
talking about what's commonplace you saw
a man with two heads yes
i did no you didn't none of your
business where you did not
none of your business did you see a man
with two heads
i told you i'm not telling you yeah i'm
not getting into it everything you're
saying today is suspect
everything please everything coco coco
doesn't belong
in in in in breakfast i'll tell you look
i'll give you this i'll give you this
point coco here's my beef
this sucks it sucks it smells not good
it doesn't look like
something it's also a big brown box it's
just lame you you know you're touting
the vibrance of fruity pebbles and
that's not what you're arguing now i
pull up a box
it looks like a problem it's just like a
big brown ugly disgusting
appetizer more importantly so
i feel like i am looking at a screen
24 hours a day 365 days a year
as the kids would say 24 7 3 3 6 5.
uh and i got to tell you it's if it's
lose
yeah if it's not news it's editing it's
if it's not editing it's news
if it's not editing and news it's social
media
it's everything from the windows to the
walls it's writing yeah right right
right
so here's my point you need
to unplug and that's easier said than
done but one of my favorite ways to rest
my eyes
okay is to have a great pair of wireless
earbuds
now here's what i don't like about the
wireless earbuds they're too
dang expensive which is why i like
raycon ray connie or bugs no dangling
wires or stems get in the way here these
are bluetooth earbuds they come in a
range of stylish colors
and they are always with comfortable
in-ear fits
for a more discreet look i've used these
things how's the battery
great battery life we're talking about
six hours of play time
you can just unplug for a while man and
the best part is
they make great sound accessible to
everyone these are not super
high high-priced you know uh elitist you
know
your elitist pinky up in the air earbuds
and they're also not trash they're
really
they're really quality solid exactly
reliable earbuds and that's why
we're uh we're giving them a read here
exactly and raycon is offering 15
on top of their already great price 15
of all their products too not just the
buds
for our listeners and all you got to do
to get it you go to
buy raycon dot com slash taste buds
that's it
you get 15 off your entire raycon order
uh feel free to grab a pair and a spare
really and that's it fifteen percent off
at buy raycon dot com slash taste buds
that's by raycon dot com slash taste
buds
earbuds for the taste buds i gotta tell
you something right now
i uh i don't know if you like me but
i've been worried about internet
security for a while now i don't like
people selling my information taking it
or anything like that
i like to know that when i go online
it's on cloud secure and that's why i've
been using this
expressvpn express ppv yeah have you
heard about it yeah
you have so you know that expressvpn is
an app that reroutes your internet
connection through your secure service
so your isp can't see the sites you
visit
i see yes yeah it doesn't matter if
you're on the uh if you get your
internet from verizon or comcast joe but
uh isps in the us can legally sell your
information at companies i don't know if
you know that also
expressvpn keeps all your information
secure
it's incognito no incognito mode doesn't
even do what expressvpn does even if
you're using incognito mode they still
get reports of every website you've ever
visited
that's why expressvpn also keeps all
your information secure by encrypting
100 of the data
uh with the most powerful encryption
service so it's available on all your
devices
i don't know i don't want many people to
hear your phones or computers even your
smart tv so there's no excuse to not be
using it i've been using it now for
about four years no joke
it's really affordable but i mean okay
if we wanted to we should probably offer
something to the listeners i don't know
if you want to
i don't know if we want to tell them
about it outright if you want to get in
on it right now
i would say just protect your online
activity today with the vpn rated number
one by cnet and wired and if you want to
visit our exclusive link show
it's expressvpn.com tastebuds
and you get three extra months free on a
one-year package
did you get what i was picking up and
putting down e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
tastebuds that's expressvpn.com
tastebuds to learn more if you want to
okay but let's keep it between us more
importantly
hold on a second we need to leave let's
pause
let's pause the argument for a second we
need to have a talk with pimp
did you see how he just spelled coco
pimp would how old are you 30
29 29 i mean jesus christ that's the
second thing you spelled today that was
so crazy
pimp spelled coco co space cm
well you're probably yeah i think pimps
are all looking at like uh
i don't know this kid makes more money i
think
i think that my father ever did his life
my father worked his ass off for 45
years
right that's how he spelled coco
there's no justice in this world
[Laughter]
that's what's happening but look coco
pebbles coco
crispies also sucks i will give you this
argument i will give you this argument
pick
it is not i don't like poco crispies
look more like
what cocoa pebbles should look like than
cocoa pebbles
that's it and coco pebbles look more
like whatever cocoa pebbles are amazing
if you put a bowl of cocoa pebbles and
cocoa crispies in front of me and said
which one you think is pebbles and which
one do you think is crispy's i'd choose
the christmases pebbles and the pebbles
that's crazy no you wouldn't now i don't
know if that really makes a difference
in my argument it doesn't but i'm just
saying like get a hold of your partner i
was about to give you
a i was about to give you a point in uh
for your team
i don't like that it's called cocoa
pebbles it should be called chocolate
pebbles
okay because it's not cocoa flavored it
doesn't taste like hot cocoa it tastes
like chocolate right
that's that so so i have a problem with
the name coco it's fun more fun though
i will say this perspective every
positive argument i made about cocoa
pebbles with the exception of the
vibrance visual argument
uh or i mean i mean that i made about
fruity pebbles you could apply to cocoa
pebbles
the texture arguments it's the same
experience whatever except you end up
with an even better result which is a
chocolate milk in the bowl
and i will say this the pebble itself
works so well on its own that they were
able to add
two drastically different flavors to it
and it
still works in both scenarios you cannot
say that about fruit loops
you can't they don't have cocoa loops
they don't have them i'm sure they have
variations but i'm not talking about
cocoa lose i'm talking about froot loops
and you'll talk about cocoa pebbles and
i will say that i feel like i win this
argument
with even just one point i i the
consistency and texture of pebbles
of cocoa pebbles after 90 seconds in
milk tastes like you are eating
a pile of cold milk soaked
excrement well cold doesn't it's cereal
sal it's all cold but but this
is it's this it's all milk so it's it's
wild the texture
i wish i could this is the first time i
ever really wish i could eat something
on
everyone says eat it while you're on
there i'm like you don't want to hear us
chew we've already had it there's no
point it's a waste of time it's dead air
i wish i could eat cocoa pebbles right
now and have you eat it because the
consistency
this is what it feels like it feels like
ready it feels like
mush at 90 seconds in milk
your whole bowl it smells feels like
that's not like
a mud pie it feels like it feels like it
feels like this
phlegm it's got this weird slimy coating
on it
that feels like a mixture of not true
versus like
that's what it really does it's got this
really really weird sheen over it that's
not true
it's so soggy but then there's this
weird invisible like
netting that holds it together that when
you
swirl it on your tongue it it's it's it
tastes like
phlegm okay but it's like chocolate
pebbly phlegm but if you wanna
but if you wanna talk in extremes which
i'll allow you to do then i'm gonna talk
in extremes
versus what a bowl of actual pebbles
that can sit in the milk for an hour and
never get soft
i would say and rip your mouth any
cereal name
any cereal in production
i don't even know a close second to
fruity pebbles
as far as you got 60 seconds to eat you
mean
no fruity pebbles we're talking cocoa
pebbles cocoa peppers sorry cocoa
pebbles
pebbles pebbles i don't i i don't think
you could name another cereal that
off the top of your head that is ruined
within 60 seconds
it's gone within 60 seconds the mascot
should be nicholas cage
that's coco pebbles okay you got 60
seconds to eat it or it literally tastes
like you're eating
like like like like like bird [ __ ]
it does stop it does [ __ ] it does it
feels like
what it feels like it feels like count
chocula's
[ __ ] oh stop it you're nuts
it's this weird the biggest con you're
making about
the biggest con you're making about
pebbles is the biggest strength
that consistency is amazing and it
doesn't take 60 seconds it takes a hell
of a lot longer because i look forward
to that consistency and i gotta wait
you have nerve a hell of a a lot longer
i got away
by that yes it takes 60 seconds a hell
of a lot longer yeah what's a hell of a
lot longer
i don't know 120 two minutes versus
60 seconds two minutes two minutes let's
go to the let's go to the phones let's
see who's got the best comments this
week
froot loops by the way coco pebbles it
just reminds me it's it's you know what
the vibrance of the fruit both in smell
texture taste
and sight it's more of a like a a
morning
wake-me-up it's more of like let me
start my day i'm pouring a bunch of
great colors into a bowl
it's it's it's fruity it's lively yeah
it's lively
it's the way i want to start my day it's
a pick-me-up it's bright
puts me in the right mood i'll tell you
when i get the same effect from a bowl
of
brown [ __ ] and coconut sometimes now
you're shoving chocolate into your mouth
at nine
more chocolate you know and it gets the
same effect as fruity pebbles what i'll
often do is i'll go into the bathroom
and i'll open the back of the toilet
tank and i'll pull out the blue thing
and i'll sniff it directly
and i'll go that's kind of like fruity
pebbles right there a nice chemical
whiff first thing in the morning i can't
i don't know a weird color that doesn't
exist
i think that i've never poured a bowl of
cereal and like let me eat a bunch of
urinal cakes
right now i don't make the connection
let me smell it i don't make that
connection let's go to the let's go to
the phone coco pebbles
coco so zane uh at zane
zilkin says froot loops is the cereal
for man children who peaked in
elementary school
thank you zane give me a break i don't
put any stock in that whatever because
everyone loves the loops
there's one from cassandra the fun is
even the name is even more fun
it's we're reading the comments but i
didn't you you went ahead i didn't say
go ahead no we have to go
we have to move root and loop like loop
fruit is a fun word we spend too much
time on [ __ ]
i love the double o's i love the
branding i love that i love a loop
loop is fun i'm gonna get a bowl of
loops it's just fun fruit loops
it's phonetically more fun cocoa pebbles
is just
just it's just in every way in every way
froot loops
and the name the color the texture the
smell the mask you can you can harangue
all you want we've been through it
all right uh here's one three bowls and
you drop out
no joking i don't know how to say this
handle no joking each fruit loop has the
same flavor thank you very much
cardboard also thanks for the gray milk
at the end of the bowl
oh that's a great point i forgot that
froot loops leaves you with gray milk no
it depends on the loops that you have i
i know i don't grade milk
the best part about cocoa pebbles isn't
even the cereal it's the chocolatey milk
afterwards
i would rather have a lovely fruity
treat than a mushy soggy gross blob
oh wow she went both ways on us yeah
what does that even mean
wow both subpar cereals don't agree to
be honest but i take the pebbles
because of the one-of-a-kind chocolate
milk you get ah
with the the chocolate milk now is gonna
do me in here
gotta be fruit loops cocoa pebbles isn't
even the best pebbles i'd rather eat
actual pebbles
that's what i'm saying babe you're gonna
bring cocoa pebbles to the fruit party
i couldn't bring i tr i told we wanted
to do fruity pebbles she said it was too
similar we ended up arguing fruity
pebbles anyway
you said you wanted to do a chocolate
cereal no we used you said it was too
similar i would have just targeted
what it was listen you should have went
somewhere else oh god apparently
i was a 94 year old child because i
didn't have either of these as a kid
and i was like hell for yeah crackling
oprah
crocodile brand first time i ever tried
it was during the pandemic shout out
kraken old bran though
because i i get it bonnie mcfarlane
which one has shrimp tails yeah you
couldn't want cinnamon toast crunch
that's it that seems to be good also
first of all
i wouldn't pee on cinnamon toast crunch
and i mean that wow i'm a golden grahams
man
get cinnamon toast crunch out of my face
you should know that was the original
match was golden grant but you didn't
feel strongly about cinnamon toast
crunch no no the original match we're
gonna do was fruit loops where's gold
and green yeah and then
i think you would have had a better
chance with golden ground i don't know
man
a lot of the comments are saying i got a
shot here i can't believe froot loops is
winning them shits taste like processed
and the milk
doesn't even slap at the end and that
cocoa bird would be toucan sans
ass any day of the week yeah dude
what cocoa bird there's a cocoa i forgot
the cocoa pebbles sometimes it's a
coconut
like mascot oh really so they're just
ripping
off of froot loops how dare they put a
bird on that box chocolate bird
a chocolate bird they had the
flintstones martha
fred flinstone's not good enough bonnie
rubble's not good enough they had to go
get a bird i
i would vote that as the best comments
froot loops are the cool ant of the
family
full of vibrant colors and awesome taste
cocoa pebbles they are that weird uncle
in the corner at your family get
together
bland and not full of much excitement i
i'm with you delaney all right coco
pebbles are for neanderthals
that's why they have the flintstones
advertising fruit loops are better by a
mile
and added bonus track they don't look
like rat droppings that's what i said
they
i said they look like bird [ __ ] she said
rat [ __ ] the point though
the common connection is [ __ ]
uh keep scrolling pimp if you don't mind
i'd rather put cardboard and milk
instead of eating froot loops it
requires more fatigue fruit loops
by the time i'm almost done with them
it's mush toucan sam can
[ __ ] off literally a mood a food made
for birds
that's our winning comment so far let me
see who that said that
no not kevin listen kevin by the way he
has the stones
to say that they they turn to mush as
soon as you put him in milk
he completely discredited it that's
right completely discredited
not another cereal that comes as close
to the pebbles as getting mushy and milk
i mean give me a break fruit circles
don't turn your milk to chocolate milk
cocoa pebbles over everything
this is where we're going to land okay
it's chocolate versus fruit that's where
we're going to land right
and and and i'll take chocolate over
fruit i can't believe this many people
don't care or like
i'll take chocolate i don't like a
straight fruit cereal which is why i
like
love cocoa i mean sorry captain crunch
with crunch berries because it's fruit
mixed
with with a with a more uh uh earthy
flavor
i love everyone's like you get chocolate
pebbles but they're not
they're not counting the beautiful cocoa
peppers that you get
at the end of fruit loops now don't give
me any of that chocolate milk [ __ ]
because fruit loops gives you a sweet
colorful milk with little specks of
delicious cereal shows shut up
all right that's great that's a great
comment amity
uh scroll up a little bit she says also
chocolate in the morning is a sin to a
man
and one should be ashamed to pick such
over a fruity delicious bowl of heaven
first thing in the morning my brother
prefers cocoa pebbles the fruit loops
and he is a failure to my family and
society
all right amity wins our best comment
follow amity at amity e
hansen that's a-m-i-t-y-e-h-a-n-s-e-n
on twitter amity wins our best comment
uh and she gets a uh or he he she
whatever uh they get a uh a retweet uh
i couldn't see the thumbnail so uh but
anyway whoever
whoever you are amity thank you that was
a great comment all right ready to go to
the
foe uh let's see who wins here can't
believe i spelled 15
000 votes i think we got more than that
but i can see that's when he pulled that
page up we're gonna have way more than
that
i can't believe i spoke
oh my god wow oh my god
whoa a one percent difference wow
that's way closer than i thought it was
gonna be no idea it was going to be that
close
me neither i i thought fruit loops was
going to take it like i got fruit loops
is arguably a top five cereal of all
time
and if anything cocoa pebbles wasn't as
popular as fruity pebbles
i am in shock actually i give you i tip
my hat to you
because coco pebbles i thought was gonna
be dominated one percent is nearly as
close as we can get to uh
to a tie that is wild that said you did
win
by a percentage and i'll take that
because i've been i've been getting
cream lately
who would have thought that this could
be a potential contender later for a
rematch
i never would have guessed that honestly
and i met my argument 100
but i was like i'm gonna get creamed
everybody loves fruit loots
loops it's classic you know blah blah
blah i'm gonna get creamed with the
cartoon cereal i'm going with but i even
do but i do like it better
i can't believe it's this close
holy [ __ ] that's wild all right
well wow i almost lost that imagine i
lost with froot loops that would have
been
i bet you because i didn't spell it
f-r-o-o-o-t i apologize
please don't send letters we're off to a
good start today
folks that's our show yeah
yeah baby oh you got to say this i still
love you babe i still love you
i still love you thanks for listening
everybody we'll be back
with new episodes uh well let's not even
say because these might
air out of order or whatever so but uh
we'll be back thank you for listening
thank you for subscribing to the no
pressure network thank you for following
taste buds keep leaving the comments
keep leaving the reviews
keep downloading the audio podcast it's
all free wherever you get your stuff
we love you we thank you goodbye
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two foods gonna fight but only one food
can be right taste buds man yeah they're
coming to the mic i'm talking taste buds